god
is three in one
but the enemy is a plagiarist and has
his own parody of the godhead
so join the word inspired sabbath
october 23 at 2 o'clock p.m eastern
standard time
for a q a session with elder randy skeet
on the satanic
trinity special guests include anthony
ralph
kadisha modest and george francis
questions from the live audience will
also be taken even if not directly
related to the topic
this program will be live streamed from
zoom to denisha mccurchion's youtube
channel and personal in the word
inspired facebook pages
the links are in the description of this
video feel free to like share and
subscribe
we welcome your prayers and
participation as we prepare for the
return of our lord and savior jesus
christ
thanks and god bless
welcome and happy sabbath again to q a
with elder randy skeet on the word
inspired i am your host denisha
mccurchion and i'm joined by special
guests elder randy skeet brother anthony
ralph sister kadisha modest and brother
george francis today we are talking
about the satanic trinity and we'll be
answering questions like what is the
satanic trinity and its purpose
what do prophetic symbols in the bible
represent
literally feel free to stay tuned for
the remainder of this program and post
your questions in the ch chats
so that we can answer them if time
permits
let's begin with a word of prayer
dear lord we thank you for your grace
and your mercies they are new every
morning great is thy faithfulness we
thank you father for this opportunity to
get into your word and i actually
forgive us of our sins and rain down
your holy spirit upon your manservant
elder randy skeet and guide him father
even put your words in his mouth so that
as he answers the questions we would all
be edified drawn closer to you and even
prompted to study your word more
we thank you for hearing and answering
this prayer in jesus name amen
all right everyone we are joined by
special guest elder randy skeet
and he studied at oakwood university and
also graduated from the seventh-day
adventist theological seminary at
andrews university for the ministry he
is a sincere and humble man of god who
has dedicated his life to taking the
gospel to all the world near and far
high and low so that god's name will be
glorified through his work i ask once
again that you listen be reverent and
think as he speaks please welcome elder
randy skeet
we are going to allow elder randy skeet
to
give his opening remarks
as we begin the q a session of this
program
am i audible dr denisha
yes you are audible all right i am
grateful as i always am to god for this
glorious privilege to be a part of this
program to try to make thus set the lord
as
comprehensible as possible to those who
are listening that they might through
this knowledge develop a closer
relationship with god and someone may be
freed from the chains and the bondage of
error and so my good sister thank you
again for extending the invitation to me
i'm very very grateful
and i pray that the god will bless the
program from beginning to end and at the
end of it all
first god may be glorified and secondly
all of us blessed through the ministry
of the world thank you so much
amen will we extend sincere thanks to
you elder randy skeet for continually
joining on these programs so that
questions can be answered and god's name
be glorified we really appreciate your
ministry your time your family and
dedication to this work of the gospel
and even this ministry the word inspired
so we begin with our first question
what is the satanic trinity and what is
its purpose
the satanic trinity is a reference to
three entities that combine to oppose
the people of god
they are introduced to us in revelation
12 and revelation 13.
now before we get into revelation 12 and
13 let me tell you something about the
devil the devil likes to copy the
techniques of god
god uses agents in the doing of his
business christ is an agent of god the
church is an agent of god
individuals are agents of god
nature is an agent of god i should say
creation
god uses agents well the devil does the
same thing we see that very clearly in
the garden of eden he used his agent the
serpent
having successfully used that agent he
then used eve as the second agent and
through her
instrumentality he got adam to fall
satan uses agents as god uses agents
now keeping this in mind god requires
worship
satan also wants worship that was the
third temptation he presented to jesus
christ and so the devil copies the
techniques of god
in acts chapter 2 verse 1 the bible says
and when the day of pentecost was fully
come they were all with one accord and
in one place
when stephen was stoned in acts chapter
7 they were all with one accord
installing stephen because unity is
strength and so i say again for emphasis
satan copies
mimics
the techniques of god now having said
that we as bible believers we know
there's the father son the holy spirit
satan has his satanic trinity now let's
go to revelation 12 and revelation 13.
now i didn't get a chance to pray so let
me pray now before i go any further
father in heaven put your words in my
mouth i pray remember the promise of
exodus 4 12 which you made to moses now
therefore go and i will be with thy
mouth
and teach you what thou shalt say do
that for me now i pray in jesus name
amen
in revelation 12 we read from verse 1
and they appeared a great wonder in
heaven a woman clothed with the sun
and the moon under her feet and upon her
head a crown of twelve stars
and she being with child cry prevailing
in birth and pain to be delivered
at the first level of interpretation
that's mary who was heavily pregnant
with christ at a higher level it is the
church of god that was persecuted by
this dragon which now comes in in verse
three and they appeared another wonder
in heaven and behold a great red dragon
having seven horns seven heads and ten
horns and seven crowns upon his heads
and he still drew the third part of the
stars in heaven and it cast him to the
earth and the dragon stood before the
woman which was ready to be delivered
for to devour her child as soon as it
was born and so we're introduced to
hostility between the dragon and the
woman
in verse 7 now
john takes us way back into a far
distant past to explain the hostility he
describes in verses 3 to 5 of revelation
12. so we have the woman then we have
she's opposed by the dragon
now in verse 17 the dragon made efforts
to corrupt the work of the woman he did
not succeed in verse 17 of revelation 12
the bible says and the dragon was wroth
with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed which keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus
christ listen to verse 17 carefully the
dragon was wroth with the woman he was
angry and went to make war with the
remnant of her seed the last part of the
woman's descendants the the last
remaining portion the remnant that's
those living in these last days in a
very special way and the last days of
course began in 1798 according to
prophecy that's the last times the last
days began prophetically in 1798.
now the dragon went to make war with
this remnant now here is how he does
that war
we end revelation 12 in verse 17 he went
to make war now in chapter 13 verse 1
were introduced to one of his agents
revelation 13 verse 1 and i stood up on
the sand of the sea and saw a beast rise
up out of the sea having seven heads and
ten horns and upon his horns ten crowns
and upon his heads the name of blasphemy
and the beast which i saw was like under
a leopard and his feet was the feet of a
bear and his mouth as the mouth of a
lion and the dragon gave him his power
and his seat and great authority
now here we have
the other entity which is what is called
the leopard-like beast it is also the
man of sin it is also the uh the
antichrist it is also the middle horn
all those terms apply to the same entity
which jon saw coming up out of the sea
this is one of the agents that the devil
uses
excuse me to wait war against the
remnant of the woman that part of the
woman's descendants living in the last
days
the other entity comes up in verse 11
and i beheld another beast coming up out
of the earth and he had two horns like a
lamb and he spake as a dragon and he
exerciseth all the power of the first
beast before him now
so we have the dragon in revelation 12
we have the leopard like this or the man
of sin or the little or or the
antichrist or the son of perdition all
of those terms apply to this power in
revelation 13 1 to 10. the third one is
the beast in revelation 13 11-18 these
three are make up the satanic trinity
satan
is the head he may be regarded as the
satanic father because he gives power to
those two entities if you read verse 4
of revelation 13 and they worship the
dragon which gave power unto the beast
but verse 12 tells us of the other
beasts that came up from the earth he
exercises all the power of the first
beast before him so the the power the
beast of verse 1 to 10 of revelation 13
has is the same power the beast of
verses 11 to 18 has
the power is given to them by the dragon
who represents satan and so we have
satan
the leopard-like beast
and the two horned beasts those three
make up the satanic trinity and their
this their purpose is to destroy the
remnant of the seed of the woman and to
sabotage the work of the gospel that has
been commissioned to the remnant of the
woman's sea
that is the satanic trinity
in some kind of a nutshell
satan trying to mimic the powers of
heaven
amen amen thank you for really breaking
that down elder scheme
even starting from revelation chapter 12
the church of god and the fact that the
enemy is set out his ultimate design is
to keep us from connecting to god to
keep us from the kingdom to destroy us
that's right we do not have salvation
we also have to note that the enemy is a
master con artist
yes he is by deception so he copies god
changes a few things so that he can
distract us
from
the truth and i believe that's one of
the reasons in matthew 24 that jesus
three different times said take heed
that you're not deceived he says all the
prophets are coming will come in my name
people will say i am christ they're low
he is there
this is the methodology of the enemy
dragon the devil himself the leopard
like beast and the false prophet that's
right in revelation 11 revelation 13
verse 11
work together to destroy god's people
and note as elder skeet said this is the
remnant the last the people god's people
in the last moments of earth's history
so the war is waging right now
even for our lives
and the question is on whose side
are we standing and the issue of worship
because if you look at revelation 13 in
verse 4 the bible says and they worship
the the dragon which gave power unto the
beast and they worship the beast now the
beast of course is a religious system
worship is
is suggests that this beast is a
religious system and so people
ignorantly worship this beast
but the beast got the power from the
dragon so consequently by worshiping the
beast of following the beast you are
ultimately following statement because
the power of the beast is the power of
satan
if you bow before an idol you're
actually bowing before satan this needs
to be understood and so the issue is
worship in verse 8 of revelation 13 and
all that develop on the earth
shall worship him meaning the beast but
in worshiping the beast ultimately the
worship is directed to satan and since
he deceiveth the whole world revelation
12 9 without knowing it most of the
world regardless of the religious
behavior are actually worshiping the
devil
and they need to be given the light of
truth that their eyes may be open that
they may switch their allegiance from
the enemy to the savior jesus christ
amen amen elders keep you know that goes
to show that not only is war being waged
against us but we also have a work to do
yes because god's people should be
taking the gospel of the kingdom to all
the world for a witness in fact jesus is
not going to come unless we give that
trumpet a certain sound and it's
important for us while satan is you know
parading the counterfeit of god's system
of worship that we uphold god's standard
of truth
amen
so thank you so much elder skeet we have
identified the satanic trinity and their
purpose
namely the dragon which is the devil
the leopard-like beast
and also the beast of revelation 13 11
the false prophet um which comes up out
of the earth and eventually makes an
image to the beast so let's hold let's
be bold we said the dragon is the devil
well let's identify the other two that
was the next question
okay the beast of revelation 13 1-10 is
the papal system
and the beast of
revelation 13 1 11-18 is the united
states
those are the three entities and we know
from prophecy that the beast and his
functioning will be replicated by
something called the image of the beast
which will be promoted by the united
states which is symbolized by the beast
of revelation 13 11 through 18. and so
we identify them not to cause
negative feelings but to open people's
eyes you see the devil's most powerful
agent is a religious system why do i say
that it is not so much the beast of
revelation 13 11 to 18 but the one of
thirteen one to ten why listen again to
revelation 13
one to two and i stood upon the sand of
the sea and saw abyss rise up out of the
sea having seven heads and ten horns and
up open his horns ten crowns and up on
his heads the name of destiny and the
beast which i saw was like unto a
leopard and his feet was the feet of a
bear and his mouth as the mouth of a
lion what we have is an animal that
incorporates all the qualities of the
four kingdoms of daniel 7 the kingdom of
babylon needleportion greece and iran
all of which contributed to the
persecution of god's people to various
degrees of severity and so this single
entity combines all
you see
babylon was just babylon
neither person was just made of persian
greece just greece wrong just rome this
unusual beast is a condemnation of
all and so it is the most deadly weapon
the devil can wield and it is a
religious system which means that
attending church means very little to
the devil or to god unless you were in
the right system
where thus saith the lord is preached
because satan his master stroke is to
use a religious system to preach error
no one expects ever from a pulpit but
that's exactly what the devil does
all right
amen thank you all the skeet for ants
for delineating that that the
leopard-like beast represents the people
system and the united states of america
the false prophet and we're going to be
talking about the image of the beast and
what exactly that is as well but i just
want to underscore what elder skeet said
the fact that coming to church
or any system of going to church is not
enough to keep us from deception in fact
if we take a look at second
thessalonians chapter 2 verses 3 and 4
paul is speaking speaking about the man
of sin and we know the man of sin
correlates to
that i'm leopard like beast here's what
paul says
let no man deceive you by any means
for that day shall not come except there
come a falling away first what is that
of falling away from the truth and that
sin be revealed the son of perdition and
watch verse 4 who opposes and exalteth
himself above all that is called god or
that is worshipped remember elvis keeps
said it's all about worship
so that he as god
sits in the temple of god showing
himself that he is god
so when the devil comes he's not going
to say i'm the devil he's going to say
i'm trying
he's going to
and we know that one of the titles of
the pope is uh god's representative he
takes the place of god on earth
that is mentioned numerous times in the
writings of the church he takes the
place of god on earth there is no
forgiveness of sins but you can't go
around the pope to be forgiven of the
church you see so yes that this this
beast takes or assume or tries to take
the place of god but that does not work
for those who know what the bible
teaches
but the deception is very very powerful
yes yes in fact one of the titles is by
um vicar a ficker of christ so in the
place of christ
i believe on the trip on the pope's
triple crown in uh the vatican it has
the inscription vicarious philly i die
biker of god have mercy
all right so
just to make it clear elderski yes you
spoke about certain symbols like a
dragon
beast um the
beast that comes out of the earth that
has two horns like a lamb but speaks as
a dragon but let's just define what
these symbols are prophetically so what
does all rights represent in bible
prophecy and uh
horns crowns the earth okay
a beast represents a kingdom in daniel
chapter seven
uh daniel sees four beasts in verse four
because he's a lion verse five a bear
six a leopard seven and eight this
non-descript beast in verse seventeen
these four these beasts which are four
are four kings which shall arise out of
the earth and so a king means represents
the very kingdom of very nation so
beasts are kings or kingdoms verse 23 of
daniel 7 thus he said the fourth beast
shall be the first kingdom upon earth
and shall be diverse for all kingdoms
and shall divide the horror of and
thread it down and break it in pieces
and the ten horns out of this kingdom
are ten kings of salaries now
beasts therefore represent kingdoms
horns represent kingdoms as well a horn
can represent the head of that kingdom
or the kingdom itself as in the case of
alexander he was the notable horn in
daniel 8 which was broken into two of
course of daniel 7
the greece is a leopard with four heads
meaning the same thing and so a beast is
a kingdom a horn is a kingdom or a
person
representing that kingdom amen
a throne simply represents rulership the
throne represents rulership and i think
the list also has water or the sea the
sea represents multitudes of people
revelation 17 verse 15 and he saith unto
me the waters which now sees where the
city are peoples and muslims and
nations and towns and so seas represent
multitudes of people the earth now
you've got to be careful with the earth
the earth can represent a barren place
very sparsely populated or the earth can
seem to be the earth itself because in
revelation 12 12 the bible says
therefore rejoicing heavens and he that
dwell in them war to the inhabitants of
the earth and of the sea for the devil
is come down unto you having great wrath
because you know that they have put a
short time in that verse it literally
means the earth which is the
the so-called property of the devil
because he overthrew adam but of course
through his resurrection and sacrifice
christ legally brought it back and so
the earth in revelation 12 12 literally
means the earth
but when we read revelation 13 verse 11
and i saw another and i beheld not a
beast coming up out of the earth it
means a place with very few people
living in opposition to the seas which
represent teeming populations
beautiful beautiful thank you so much
elderski
thank you so much for that there's one
other well you spoke about the throne
but what about crowns what do crowns
represent because we see that the beast
yes
you know we will reign with
christ uh revelation 5 verse 9
revelation 21 22 5 we shall reign with
christ revelation 20 also tells us we
shall reign with christ of course second
timothy chapter 4 verse 8 we shall
receive a crown jesus christ a crown is
put on the head of a ruler we shall
reign with christ crowns represent
rulish
beautiful right so much of this so
friends
kingly power
rulership kennedy power all right go
ahead beautiful rulership kingly power
so we've defined some symbols
where the beast represents a kingdom
where horns represent kings sea right
multitudes of people the earth
literal earth which christ has reclaimed
from the enemy but it can also represent
a place sparsely populated which is in
contrast
and that's right that's right we have
also defined that crowns represent
rulership and holy
amen we've also defined the satanic
trinity and their purpose which is to
destroy god's people where the dragon is
the devil where the leopard-like beast
is the papacy and the false prophet
represents the united states of america
and i know we kind of breeze through
breathe through that but friends i
encourage you to study on your own how
we are able to identify the united
states of america with uh the beast of
revelation 13 11 the papacy with the
leopard-like beast the dragon well the
bible plainly saves it in revelation
verse 9.
but hopefully we'll also if god permits
do a session really breaking down the
historical aspect to this prophecy
now if you are you just said the bible
clearly identifies the devil because
that is where the problem really lies
the others are merely agents of the
devil and so the devil is unmasked
clearly and plainly revelation 12 9 the
dragon is is is a serpent revelation
21st 2 he is plainly exposed because he
is the problem he is the power behind
the beast of revelation 13 1-10 on the
beast of revelation 13 11 through 18 and
so he is identified and then we now have
to use our minds um to figure out who
the other two are
and with just a small effort guided by
the spirit we come to the conclusions of
course we talk about the roman system
and the united states but the devil is
clearly identified because he is the
problem
amen amen in fact indeed the devil is
the problem and note how we are saying
the roman system that doesn't mean that
roman catholics are outside of god's way
to bring in or someone that is not
quote-unquote seventh-day adventists has
no opportunity to accept the gospel the
issue is with the system of worship that
work
yes that works by deception to lead
god's people astray even as the serpent
in the garden of eden worked upon eve
who prophetically would represent a
church and deceive her and here we are
today let me say this about a system and
it's not very pleasant
when christ was crucified
the church worked with the system
to crucify christ
in these last days we have to be careful
that god's remnant people do not
cooperate with the satanic system by the
choices do we make and the way we
interpret the bible or the way we try to
to reduce the severity of some of our
teachings severity is a bad word but
weaken the strength of some of our
teaching you know there's a movement to
stop saying the remnant church of god uh
don't emphasize the sabbath don't
emphasize the ten commandments these
kinds of actions have us cooperating
with the system and so as the system
found help from the church of god in in
the days of christ when he was crucified
because pilate wanted to let jesus go
their church said crucify him and i say
the church because the church was
represented by the leaders in these last
days as we're up against the most
powerful instrument the devil has ever
used the beast of revelation 13 1-10 we
must be careful in our preaching our
teaching the way we function all our
institutions our churches our schools
our hospitals that we do not cooperate
with the system represented by the
beasts of revelation 31-10 we have to be
very careful we don't help the devil to
do his work
amen amen
thank you so much elder skeet
charge for that charge
so now we will transition i'm going to
bring on brother anthony ralph to ask
the next three set of questions and
friends
this next set is actually where i don't
want to see the meat and potatoes are
because well the this is where the heavy
duty stuff comes in we're going to be
talking well i'll let brother anthony do
that for the anthony you can ask the
next three questions to elder skeet
alright i don't see him as yet on again
so other ski let's start with question
three all right
the dragon gives the leopard like beast
it's power
and great authority okay anthony i see
you're on
um i'll just complete the question
what are ways we see the power
seat and great authority of the beast
and we've identified this beast as the
people system
all right let me pray again father in
heaven as we continue on this most
profound subject
give us truth
clarity of expression i pray and let the
spirit of truth work on the minds of
those who are listening because the
enemy is not happy in jesus name i pray
amen
revelation 13 verses 1 and 2 and i stood
upon the sand of the sea
and saw a beast rise up out of the sea
having seven heads and ten horns and
upon his horns 10 crowns and upon his
heads the names of bapsumi and the beast
which i saw was like under a leopard and
his feet was the feet of a bear and his
mouth of the mouth of the dragon
a lion and the dragon gave him his power
and his seat and great authority now
historically we traced this all the way
back to the beginnings of that was when
constantine transferred the capital of
the roman empire from rome to
constantinople in present day turkey
that was i think around 3 30
a.d when he did that this created what
may be regarded as a vacuum a power
vacuum in the city of rome if the
emperor is no longer seated in rome then
who symbolizes the power in and that
person rose to be the bishop of rome who
of course we call the pope the bishop of
rome now it became more formal when
justinian and emperor in 538 officially
he issued a decree called the create the
decree of justinian which made the
bishop of rome supreme above all other
bishops
and all matters concerning the church
had to be submitted to him and so in 538
the bishop of rome was officially by
decree of the emperor made the head and
he had not only religious but he also
had secular authority and so the power
which he and the seat and the authority
the power of course is the power to
carry out your decisions whatever they
are and at one point the the people
system had armies that fought to subdue
those who oppose its program that's
power the authority means the legal
authority to do what needs to be done
you may have the legal authority but not
the power of the might to carry it out
and of course his throne or his seat
being the seat of
rome where that where his headquarters
was that's the seat that's his throne so
the dragon gave him his power his seat
and great authority and that system has
really had great great authority it has
risen and fallen over the hundreds of
years but it is it has been and still
continues to be a most powerful system
all gifted to the system by
the enemy power
seat by the way let me make a personal
application the devil can give you
things big things
he gave to the beast power
seat and authority let me say it again
the devil can give you things he can
give you high positions he can grant you
success
in quotation marks because if god
ultimately success is failure the dragon
can the devil can give you things so
don't believe because you've got so many
things you're blessed by god the devil
can give you things
it is of god when god is involved and
the glory of god is the reason for those
things but let me say again the devil
can give you things god gives us things
that may continue to grow in his grace
the devil gives us things to fatness for
the slaughter
expression amen
thank you all the skeet well brother
anthony i'm gonna let you do your role
thank you let me
all right thank you very much sister
denise i'm so sorry the that was trying
a lot with the audio for the computer so
i had to switch to my ipad
but god is good yeah it says so we're at
question three right
i believe four now
four okay so it says the leopard-like
beast makes war with the saints
for the two months
as for revelation chapter 13 verse 5.
when in history do we see this fulfilled
and what are the ways beasts the beast
rather blasphemes god and god's name
tabernacle and heavenly host so it's
like a two-way question the first part
is
what are the ways that the beast black
beam gone
no what uh when did the production begin
that's the first part i think then the
second part is how does it last others
persecution of the church
began long before fighting
the
free
persecution of god
but when the
the three just
he made the pope the head of the church
officially made him the head of the
universal church
the period between
and yet perfectly recorded a time when
persecution of god's people continues
more intense than others it was never at
the same level of intensity all through
the period but up and down but in that
period 538 to 79 years was when
persecution raged back and forth against
the church of god as i said to varying
levels of severity from 5 38 but before
that the church was persecuted in the
days of the apostles the church was
persecuted and any persecuting power of
the church is an agent of the devil the
bible tells us clearly the spirit of
antichrist was working in the dead of
the apostle that's one of the messages
of
first john and also ii john the spirit
of antichrist was at work long before
the papacy was established it just
continued on in a glue in a you know on
a wider scale and in a more organized
way but persecution according to
prophecy
began
extending from 538 bc not bc 80 to 1798
the 1260 year period when the the dragon
working through his age the beast the
leopard-like beast harassed
the church of god
harassment goes on now but differently
now how did the beast uh lasting the
name of god
by claiming to forgive sins now in the
end
in the catholic system you cannot be
forgiven by going directly to god
you cannot
but god is not directly accessible to
you you've got through christ but to get
the christ you've got to go to the
priest you've got to go to the
sacraments you cannot go straight to god
and so the priest stands between you and
god all the system you the system takes
the place of god you see the mediator is
christ but in the church's system the
media is the priest and the sacraments
the
the sacramental system of that church
and so it stands in the place of god you
cannot go directly to god the priest
himself not only hears your confession
the priest can forgive your sins only
god can do that mark chapter 2 verse 5
to 7 who only who but god can forgive
sins also the pope is the representative
of god on earth he takes the place of
god on earth he is in a very practical
sense the visible representation of god
on earth this is blasphemy when jesus
said he was a son of god meaning he was
equal with god the jews tried to kill
him because they understood
himself god and no human being who's
only human can claim to be god and so in
these two ways principally there may be
other ways but principally these two
ways claiming to forgive since only god
can do that and taking the place of god
on earth standing between the sin of god
only christ can do that those are two
blasphemous expressions of that system
so the blasphemy the name of god and his
temple and them that dwell in heaven
amen
all right you touch elizabeth on the top
of an apple and and also on the heavenly
host how does um how does the beast
blaspheme the heavenly host in general
the heavenly host
can refer to god's people on earth
the heavenly hosts can refer to the
angels
now the beast cannot reach the angels
the beast can reach us you see
and so
we have
in heaven according to that system
a core edema
uh what is called a redemptrix the
female version of redeemer that is mary
we have in the heavenly system according
to that system the saints who died and
now are in heaven and you can pray to
them and so that is a form of blessing
the heavenly host but we as children of
god you see we are members of the
kingdom of god the kingdom of heaven is
upon you the kingdom of god is within
you we are
also spiritually part of the heavenly
host and he blasphemes
god's people through the deception that
he tries to perpetrate upon them
he blessed christ by trying to take his
place
he blessing god the father by being the
holy father on earth
thank you very much for that answer then
we had the fifth question
the beast that comes out of the earth
tell the inhabitants of the earth to
make an image to the beast
gives life to it
causes people to worship it see
revelation chapter 13 verses 14 and 15.
what is the image and its significance
the imp now the word image is important
an image precise reflection of an
original keep this in mind we were made
in the image of god we must reflect god
christ object lessons 53
69 paragraph one when the character of
christ shall be perfectly reproduced in
his people they will come to claim them
as a dawn jesus said in john 14
9 he that have seen me have seen the
father so jesus was the image of the
father we are to be the image of christ
we were made through adam in the image
of god now we were to look like god
behave like god think like god
philippians 2 verse 5 let this mind be
in you which was also in christ jesus
hebrews 12 verse 10 we are to partake of
the holiness of god second peter chapter
one verse four we must partake of the
divine nature of god we can never be god
but we must be godly and god like we
must reflect the image of god now
the mark the image of the beast is a
system just like the beast
and the horrible thing about the beast
system is is a religious system
controlling the state to enforce its
will on the population let me say it
again a religious system controlling
secular leaders to impose its will upon
the general population that very system
will be established it will be called it
will be called the image to the beast
and its creation will be fueled by
efforts from the beast of revelation 13
11 to 18
which is the united states bluntly put
the united states will lead the way in
setting up a system that is similar to
the people system and the united states
being the most influential country on
earth will lead the world in adopting
and following this system which is
apparent and simply idolatry and so the
image of the beast is a system just like
the beast no variation just like the
beast it will be initiated by this
country known for religious freedom
thank you very much for
let me say it in revelation 13 and he
had power to give life to the image of
the beast
now
the the energy behind that beast will be
this this uh
the energy behind the image of the beast
will be the beast of revelation 13 11
through 18 as verily as the energy
behind the man of sin is the energy of
satan but since the beast of revelation
13 11 to 18 exercises the same power as
the beast of revelation 13 1-10 and that
power is the devil verse 4 then the
power that motivates the image of the
beast is the same power that motivates
the beast which is satanic power
and for this is interesting
that as many as would not worship the
image of the beast should be killed
there will be a death penalty for those
who do not worship that system as verily
as there was a death penalty in the days
of daniel for those who did not bow to
the beast that nebuchadnezzar set up
sorry my brother interrupting you go
ahead
now that's okay um it's just interesting
that america um with its constitution
and all of its laws and so on affect
human rights and liberative conscience
that we would come to in history where
we're going to force the conscience to
to worship a certain that is against
god's law and the country was built on
nations in god's word so it's just
amazing that's why it's called a
lamb-like beast
yes that's right
wolves and sheep's clothing
you're welcome
yes yes welcome sister denisha for the
remainder of the questions all right
thank you thank you so much brother
anthony for asking those questions
adding the commentary and as always
thank you elder skeet for breaking down
what the image to the beast is and even
the fact that the devil will give us
things he will supposedly bless us so
friends we gotta be careful when we look
at other people and we say oh you're
blessed you're blessed i want what you
have because sometimes we don't know how
they got it that's right
now there's just one other thing that i
would like to ask elder steve it's not
the questions i had on the on the
document
all right but
we noted that one of the ways the beast
exhibits its blasphemous behavior is in
forgiving sins
now
now in john chapter 20
verses 22 and 23 this is what jesus made
how do we under the question is how do
we understand john chapter 20 verses 22
and 23 in the light that only god can
forgive sins and i'm going to read the
passage
okay
dear lord please once again forgive us
of our sins and please direct us as we
read your word thank you for your holy
spirit in jesus name amen
the word of the lord says and when he
had said this
in fact i guess i should read what jesus
said let's start from verse 21 right
said jesus to them again
peace be unto you as
as my father had sent me even
by you
and when he had said this
he breathed on them and saith unto them
receive ye the holy ghost
whosoever sins ye remit they are
remitted unto them and whosoever sins ye
retain they are retained
now
to understand that let's go to matthew
16.
let's go to matthew remember that
incident where jesus said whom do men
say that i the son of man matthew 16 13.
so peter answered verse 6 about the
christ the son of the living god
so read from verse 16 of matthew 16.
all right and simon peter answered and
said thou art the christ the son of the
living god
and jesus answered and said unto him
this is verse 17 yes blessed art thou
simon barjona for flesh and blood have
not revealed it unto thee but my father
which is in heaven a reading and i say
unto you verse 18 that thou art peter
and upon this rock i will build my
church and the gates of hell shall not
prevail against it
verse should i read verse 19 as well
and i will give unto thee the keys of
the kingdom of heaven and whatsoever
shalt bind on earth shall be bound in
heaven and whatsoever thou shalt loose
on earth shall be loosed in heaven
all right now i will give you the keys
of the kingdom the question is what is
the key of the kingdom we need to
understand that to explain john 20 22 23
and the great greater light regarding
matthew 16 19 i will give you the keys
of it is with the key of the kingdom of
heaven now jesus came to preach the
kingdom of heaven are you with me that's
what he came to preach
the kingdom of heaven is is upon you the
kingdom of heaven is within you he came
to pray so at a certain level the
kingdom of heaven represents the
principles of the kingdom of god the
principles of the gospel so the keys of
the kingdom have to do with the
teachings of jesus christ but go to
matthew 23 and read verse
14.
of verse 13 matthew 23 verse 13 read
that as we go from scripture to
scripture matthew 23 verse 13
all right father we continue to ask your
guidance
matthew 23 13.
whoa unto you
scribes and pharisees hypocrites
for ye shut up the kingdom of heaven
against men for ye neither go in your
cells
neither suffer ye them that are entering
to go in
now how do they shut up the kingdom of
heaven against men you see all of this
is has to do with uh the question you
ask
what you forgive on earth shall we
forgive in heaven he said warns you you
shut up the kingdom how is that done go
to luke 11 read verse 52.
luke talks about the same thing he uses
different language one explain the other
luke 11 52.
it reads
what were you lawyers for ye have taken
away
the key of knowledge ah
okay
the key of knowledge uh-huh keep we hold
first you entered not in yourselves and
then that were entering in he hindered
which is the same complaint christ made
in verse
13 of matthew 23 it's the same thing but
luke gives us some information to throw
light on matthew the key is knowledge
now
go back to john 20 22 23 whatsoever
who sins you forgive the forgiven who
sends you remain but in other words
whatever you do on the basis of the word
of god shall be approved in heaven as it
is done on earth all that is saying is
if you
if you judge and if you act according to
the key of knowledge according to thus
set the law that's simply what it is the
word of god whatever you do will be
approved in heaven because you're using
you're using heaven's standard of right
and wrong the word of god is heaven's
standard of right and wrong and so when
jesus said whose sins you remain they're
committed who sends you forgive you
forgive it it's not that you will
forgive sin but you will realize
that god has done something in a
person's life based on the word of god
in matthew 23 13 you shut up the kingdom
of heaven against men how do you do that
you keep from them the truth you know
this was done for years by the roman
system at one point the bible was on a
list of books that were banned you could
not read the bible knowledge was
withheld john 17 13 this is life eternal
that they might know thee the only true
god and luke explains you take away the
key of knowledge and so when the church
makes decisions based on thus said the
lord what's bound on earth is bound in
heaven but it was first bound in heaven
because it was done on the basis of thus
saith the lord so if you know the bible
says in matthew 18 if your brother
trespassed against you go and tell him
your fault if he receive you then you've
saved your brother if he doesn't hear
you of the church let him be like some
unbeliever or heretic now if you do that
it's bound in heaven because heaven said
to do that so the decision on earth is
endorsed in heaven because it was made
based on heaven's standard thus set the
lord no human being can forgive sins no
human being can determine a person's
salvation but when the church acts in
accordance with thus if the lord that
action is bound in heaven because it was
taken using heaven standard which is the
word of god thus said the lord
and so when jesus said i'll give you the
keys of the kingdom the key of the
kingdom is the word of faith
amen amen the word all right sorry take
so long with that but that's a very
serious question you asked
because the catholic church uses that to
say that we can forgive sins you see and
the bible says who can forgive sins but
god so they're not using the keys of the
kingdom to make that claim
amen amen thank you so much for making
that point of this key
and
we needed in fact we actually needed you
to actually go through and break it down
and connect verse by verse because we
cannot just use that verse to make a
blessing
a lot of
a lot of us do that including adventists
we do
that and we try to build a theology on
one verse some churches build the church
on one verse whatever position you take
must be built on here a little there
little line upon line precept upon
precept
amen amen and we know that verse in the
mouth of two or three witnesses all
three
yes everywhere will be established amen
amen so thank you elder skeet for
answering that question
all right so we're going to move on to
the next question i know we spoke about
the image of the beast but
the mark of the beast all right
let's pray again father this is very
very serious material
please talk to me as i talk to your
people in jesus name i pray amen
go to ezekiel chapter 9.
i let my friends online get that verse i
i i god bless all of you listening
review i really mean that whatever
country you're in state or neighborhood
god bless you
thank you for joining this program
ezekiel 9 we read from verse 4.
ezekiel is seeing this vision of
judgment on jerusalem
and he hears a voice
talking to the destroying angel
he said and he says unto him go through
the midst of the city
through the midst of jerusalem and set a
mark upon foreheads of the men that cry
and sigh for all the abominations that
will be done in the midst thereof in
other words destroying angel don't
destroy those with the mark on their
foreheads i'm taking this there first so
we can understand we usually use the
word mark in connection with the beast
but god also has a mark you understand
we call it the seal but since i began by
saying the devil likes to copy god's
style of operation
god has a mark the devil has a mark
follow my sabbath it is a sign between
me and the children of israel forever
exodus 31 13-17 and so god has a mark or
a seal or a sign he has a mark the word
mark is used it is he capital nine
anyone with the mark don't touch that
person of course in revelation seven
we have the the feeling of god
a mark is placed on certain people
twelve thousand from each tribe now
the mark of god the seal of god the
distinguishing outward distinguishing
mark and i use the word outward
deliberately
is the seventh of the sabbath observance
it is a sign ezekiel 20 verse 12 ezekiel
20 verse 20 exodus 31 12-17 it is a sign
between god and his people it is not a
sign between god and the whole earth
between god and his people of course his
people can come from any ethnic group if
they will accept god's standards and
god's law now god's word ultimately
accept jesus christ
god has a mark it is the sabbath and i
said an outward mark by that i mean not
a mark on your forehead that you can see
but by the outward observance of the
sabbath the god's people are attending
church they're doing what god has to do
to avoid certain things on that day they
recognize that there's holy and by their
lifestyle people see
that they're observing the sabbath
outward now god had a second mark for
the israelites which was circumcision
introduced in genesis 17 but you cannot
see circumcision are you with me you can
see it now
circumcision therefore represents the
surrender of the heart to the the truth
of god and so we're told circumcise the
foreskin of your heart and be no more
hardheaded now
the sabbath keeping is the outward side
because what's in the heart must come
out you understand let me say it again
what's inside must come out circumcision
represents the cutting off of self and
total surrender to god sabbath's
observance is the outward expression of
that total surrender to god that's the
mark well satan's mark must be similar
his mark must be similar and as verily
as
god is god the father god the son god
the holy ghost there's the devil there's
the the lad like beast and there's the
false prophet then
sunday of sunday as a legal day of
worship is the mark of the beast as a
matter of fact in some catholic writings
it is stated plainly our power to change
the day from saturday to sunday is the
mark of our authority and our power and
so we as very if
daniel locked down of the three boys had
bound to that image they've accepted the
mark of of nebuchadnezzar but by not
queen they reflected the mark of god or
the seal of god
the beast has his mark and that is
sunday as a legal day of worship i keep
saying as a legal day because right now
no one has the mark of the beast
we know what it is theoretically it is
not yet in practical operation
when a law is passed making sunday
worship the legal day of worship then we
will have in operation the mark of the
beast then we will have those those who
are wearing the mark of the beast based
on their conscious choice to follow a
manmade law in opposition to god's law
which says remember the sabbath day to
keep it holy
and so the mark of the beast is sunday
as a legal day of worship and enforced
by religious system using the secular
powers
that has not yet happened consequently
the mark of the beast is
um
a biblical fact not yet operationalized
when that law is packed and it's coming
as it did for the three hebrew boys is
coming for us
then we will have the mark of the beast
in operation and those who accept that
man-made law will have the mark of the
beast those who continue to serve god
because first the heart has been given
to him they will have the seal of god
now the seventh day sabbath is the scene
of god
sunday observance as a legal day
is the mark of the beast but no one has
the mark of the beast now because
universally there is no law requiring
sunday as the holy day i say universally
amen amen thank you
and we can stop practicing you see as
you observe a day that god does not
require you are conditioning yourselves
to receive that mark when it becomes a
law and this is very important you are
it's like preparing for the olympics you
prepare four years the olympics comes
then you you're well qualified to take
part by constant disobedience to god and
rejecting his day you make it easy for
you to accept the day when it becomes a
lawful legal holiday the violation of
which will be backed up by a death
penalty
amen amen and friends this is how we
start connecting the questions because
remember we spoke about the united
states of america and its role as the
false prophet in setting up that image
will be very key in pushing for this
universal day of worship one wednesday
and just to buttress what you have
shared elder steve i want to read these
excerpts of the first from priest brady
in an address reported in the news
elizabeth new jersey march 18 1903 and
this
review
february
1914 here's what it says
it is well to remind the presbyterians
baptists methodists and all other
christians that the bible does not
support them anywhere in their
observance of sunday
sunday is an institution of the roman
catholic church and those who observe
the day observe a commandment of the
catholic church
that's the first quotation second
quotation
they that is the protestants
deem it their duty to keep the sunday
holy why because the catholic church
tells them to do so they have no other
reason the observance of sunday thus
comes to be an ecclesiastical law
entirely distinct from the divine law of
sabbath observance yes the author of the
sunday law is the catholic church and
these are not my words that's right
these are quotations it's very simple
you know from what you said we can see
how the the beast has power supreme
power
every
christian organization
observing sunday
is obeying the catholic church it is as
simple as that because sunday as a day
of worship was not uh brought into
existence by the presbyterians they did
not exist or the pentecostals did not
exist or the lutheran did not exist it
was brought into play by the roman
church and every church that adopts it
is following the catholic church and its
authority it is as simple as that i
don't care what they say about that
church
that church is honest in declaring we
change the day it's very honest and you
have to respect honesty those churches
that talk about the catholic church and
it's while observing sunday are simply
not realizing they are obeying and they
are under the authority of the catholic
system because sanders day of worship is
a product largely of the catholic church
amen amen
and
just on a side note i know elder skeet
you had welcomed those who were tuning
in we actually had someone sister trisha
moses berkeley watching all the way from
trinidad and tobago oh god bless
trinidad and tobago
amen thank you i'm sure we have others
listening listening in from other
countries god bless all those countries
with truth
amen amen
so we're coming down to the close of all
right questions the last question i have
i know we've been focusing on revelation
chapter 13 in terms of identifying the
satanic trinity but there is a word
there for god's people in fact the bible
says
in verse 8 of revelation 13 and all that
dwell upon the earth shall worship him
whose names are not written in the book
of life of the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world all right and
again we see
well where is it okay let me just leave
it at that now the question the question
is
what are ways we can keep our names in
the lamb's book of life and exhibit the
patience and faith of the saints
let me pray father as we come to the
conclusion continue to bless please with
simple truth administered by your spirit
in jesus name amen
how do you keep your name the book of
life very very simple
obedience to god of course disobedience
through the power of the spirit let's go
to exodus 32 we'll read verses 31 to 33
as we answer that question exodus 32
31-33
in this chapter the israelites have made
a golden calf while it was made by aaron
and the church leaders all the people
worshipped the calf except the levites
of course and moses and joshua who were
up in the mountain
moses is angry but not as angry as god
god wants to wipe out the entire islamic
nation and begin anew with moses moses
intercedes on behalf of the israelites
in that sense he's functioning like
christ here's what moses says to god
exodus 32 from verse 31 and moses
returned unto the lord and said oh this
people have sinned the great sin and
have made the god of gold
yet now if thou wilt forgive their sin
but if not not me i pray thee out of thy
book which i was written so moses says
listen if you destroy them take my name
out of the book of life that's the book
he's referring to take it out
listen to what god said to moses in
verse 33
and lost it unto him whose ever have
sinned against me him will i block out
of my book the question was how can i
keep my in the book of life by doing the
opposite of what gets it out what gets
in hell is sin what keeps it in is
obedience through christ and i have to
say through christ let's go to
revelation chapter 3 and let's read
verse 5.
revelation 3 verse 5 the message to
sardis
revelation chapter 3 verse 5 these are
the words of christ
himself and christ said he that
overcometh
the same shall be clothed with white
rhema
and i will not blunt out his name out of
the book of life notice how the verse be
he that overcometh overcometh one
sin
his name will not be blotted out so the
question is how do i keep my name
continue to be faithful to christ
through obedience of faith simple as
that
amen continue to be
people to christ through the obedience
it must be faithful obedience obedience
based on the word of god you trust god's
word you trust him you do what he says
amen but all told noah to build an ark
it made no sense to him at a secular
level no one had seen reigns he obeyed
because god said it
when peter when christ told peter go
fishing again peter said look we've been
fishing all night luke chapter five but
at your work we'll go that's the
obedience of faith
that keeps our name in the book of life
simple obedience to god
and that includes this sabbath if the
knowledge of it has come to you
if you're genuinely ignorant god is
merciful
but to be genuinely ignorant you must be
able to say to god i did not know and i
had no way of knowing those two elements
must be present or you cannot claim
ignorance
amen amen
thank you so much
yes
so we've completed our formal questions
and i'll probably just ask one or two
questions that persons have sent to me
beforehand and there are a plethora of
questions but i won't be able to ask all
of them
all right
um
if you can if you can just put your
question again inside this live chat
then i'll be able to ask the question
and if any of you that are on the zoom
you have a question you would like to
axe or the skeet feel free to use the
raise your hand feature we'll unmute you
and you can pose your question
if can we give priority to the questions
already submitted
yes absolutely
yeah let's give them priority
all right so the first
oh they're just so i'll i'll start with
this one all right um crash that's the
name that i see here
okay
in fact
yeah craft
the question is for you to explain first
corinthians chapter 14 verse 34 and i
believe this is in context to women
being silent in church let me just read
the text first
chapter 14
34.
if you can explain
that
the word of the lord
says
if your women keep silence in church in
the churches for it is not permitted
unto them to speak but they are
commanded to be under obedience as also
said the law
i smile because a lot of people use that
text to silence women and say they can't
speak in the church now that's one of
the most troublesome texts in the bible
and i've not yet seen a definitive uh
statement of that i have not yet seen a
definitive treatment of that verse
let me say this because you must lose
reason when studying the bible let's
raise together
we know that there are women leaders in
the bible i didn't say a women priest i
said women leaders deborah was a judge
and the king came to her for counsel and
wisdom judges chapter four chapters four
and five when fighting the canaanites
deborah told him what to do deborah
would instruct the people that now they
have no church buildings back then but
the church is not a building it is the
gathering of god's people deborah would
instruct god's people she was not told
to keep silent we have in uh philippians
chapter four verse two and three i
beseech your audience and be synthetic
that may be of the same mind in the lord
and i entreat you true your fellow help
those women which labored with me in the
gospel they were two men who work with
paul it is not unreasonable to assume
that they help in preaching the word we
have aquila and priscilla in acts 18.
they took apollos who was very eloquent
but did not know the word very well you
read from verse 24 onward and they told
him the word because
priscilla who was the wife to acrylic
was very versed in the word and so here
was she teaching a preacher if the bible
does not teach that women cannot occupy
opposition the puppet and preach
so whatever first corinthians 14 34 says
it cannot contradict other parts of the
scripture where women clearly spoke for
god
and so so i cannot give go anywhere any
anymore beyond that
to give you uh of uh an authoritative
treaties on that verse but i can tell
you that there are women in the bible
who spoke for god so however you look at
first corinthians 14 14 34 it cannot
contradict those clear passages where
women obviously spoke for god
i did not say that the bible says women
should be priests i was said that i said
they were leaders in the church and they
spoke
and there's nothing to keep a woman from
speaking the bible says what prophesies
she should cover ahead prophesize me
speaking for god whether to one person
or to a group the bible understands that
women will prophesy or speak for god
and we can't use first corinthians 14 34
to silence them because on the surface
it looks like it is saying women should
not speak in church
amen
next question
next question this one comes from
gliazza amoroso she says
hello i followed pastors skeet question
and answer videos i have a question
genesis chapter one says god spoke and
everything created
except man and woman genesis 2 verse 19
and out of the ground god
the lord god formed every beast of the
field and every fowl of the air
and brought them unto adam to see what
he would call them and whatsoever adam
called every crete every living creature
that was the name thereof
this verse says out of the ground god
formed every beast of the field i'm
confused animals or beasts were
i guess she says animals or beasts were
created by what i guess she wants to
know did god just speak and they came to
be or did god you know physically go on
the ground and formed animals out of the
dust of the earth
now to explain that i may need another
hour which we certainly do
there is a sermon i preach called
hands-free operation
it is somewhere on youtube
someone who's curious you may try to
find that sermon but i dealt exactly
with this issue
now i have
if you read psalm 138 verse 2
it says
he has magnified his word above all his
name the word of god has priority above
everything else the righteousness of god
is the fact that god is always faithful
to his word
and that's the way we ought to be
because god's word is right he has
magnified his word
above all his name psalm 138 verse 2 the
word of god cannot be minimized at all
because that is what we are to live by
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word now
having said that genesis 1 verse 3 verse
1 in the beginning god created the
heaven and the earth
the question is how did he do that
psalm 33 verse 6 by the word of the lord
where the heavens made and all the hosts
of them by the breath of his mouth
hebrews 11 verse 3 through 5th we
understand that the worlds were formed
of frame by the word of god it is the
word of god now how are angels made
psalm 148 verses 1 2 and 3 praise you
the lord raise the lord from the heavens
praise him in the heights praising him
all his angels praising him all his
hosts verse 5 let them praise the name
of the lord for he commanded and they
were created patriots and prophets phase
38 paragraph three christ was the son of
god he had been one with him before the
angels were called into existence
god created angels by simply speaking
and this is what we learned in psalm 148
verse 5. he simply spoke and angels came
now if you look at genesis chapter 1
for every day of creation
we have the word let
let there be light
let there be a firmament let the waters
under the heavens
let the earth bring forth grass let
there be light in the firmware let the
waters
let the waters bring forth abundantly
for uh day five efficiency let the earth
bring forth living creatures let us make
man in our image we have let for every
day of creation and for everything of
creation it seems to point that
everything created was created by the
word of god now i've searched the bible
and wise writings i need to continue
doing that to look for a clear statement
which says god stood down
scooped up dirt with his hand and
laboriously formed adam and eve and
consequently every animal i have not yet
found that sometimes people point to the
expression the hand the hand of the
bible frequently bends the exercise of
authority you understand so when the
bible says lest he put forth his hand
and take and eat ultimate tree of life
when adam consumed the forbidden fruit
he did not put forth his hand to the
tree i mean he brought it to him he
didn't have to put forth his hand at all
in other words lest he exercise his will
to go eat that fruit the hand of god
frequently made the exercise of god's
sovereign will that no one can turn back
he brought out the israelites with a
stretched out arm and a mighty hand
simply means the exercise of his power
now
when i consider thy heavens the works of
life fingers the moon and the stars
which thou has now what do you mean the
works of life fingers is simply this the
exercise of god's power now listen to
this quotation this is let me pray again
father please give me simple language in
the name of jesus i appeal to you amen
listen to ellen white in the ministry of
healing page 414 paragraph five the
minister of healing page 414 paragraph
five listen very carefully
everything material or spiritual
stood up
before the lord god the lord jehovah at
his voice
and were created for his own purpose now
listen again
everything material
or spiritual
stood up before the lord jehovah at his
voice
and were created for his own purpose she
goes on to say the heavens and all the
hosts of them the earth and all things
therein came into existence by the
breath of his mouth
now in the same book we got page 415 now
paragraph one the ministry of healing
page 415 paragraph one i will quote the
quotation but i'll leave out two words
here's the quotation
through christ
a personal god created man and endowed
him with intelligence and power let me
say it again through christ and that's
very true ephesians 3 9 hebrews 1 2 the
father created through christ christ was
the agent of creation he did it but for
the father now through christ
a personal god created man and endowed
him with intelligence and power
keep those words in your mind through
christ a personal god created man now
let me give you the whole quotation
through christ the word
a personal god created man and endowed
with intelligence and power now why
would she say through christ the word
through christ the word a personal god
created man and endowed with it what i'm
trying to get to consider this is not a
doctrine i'm trying to spread i just
want you to consider that all of
creation was by the word of god there's
another reason well let me go to the
book of uh let's go to john the
resurrection of lazarus
when jesus says take me away the stone
they said lord by this time he stinketh
now i think that's the reef in verse 39
he stinketh
and
so jesus understood what martha was
saying he has begun to be comfort in
other words what you have back behind
that stone is there in a certain sense
he's going back to dirt a dead person is
dirt effectively dust because the life
is gone you see and the lord god formed
that of the dust of the ground breathed
into his nostrils the breath of life man
became a living soul remove the breath
all you have is dust nice dust now jesus
stood outside of the tomb of the cave
and he said lazarus come forth he never
touched him
he spoke and thus came to life now
let's look at the most severe example
first corinthians 4 16 so the lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the archangel
with the trump of god and the dead and
christ shall rise first now wait a
minute wait a minute the dead in christ
that goes all the way back to abel
abel is the first saint to die as far as
we know recorded in scripture if anyone
is dust is able
he's been dead before everybody else
this man is dust in the dustiest sense
of the word
jesus will stand somewhere in heaven are
you following me he doesn't touch the
earth and he speaks and abel is formed
as a human being
he is formed as a human being along with
every other righteous person who saw
corruption meaning a decay of the body
he does not use his hands
he just speaks
now there's another principle to keep in
mind the bible teaches the power that
create is the power that maintains you
let me say that again the power that
creates you is the same power that
sustains you you can't have one power
creating and a different power
sustaining that does not work biblically
second peter chapter three read from
verse five and seven
for this they willingly are ignorant of
that by the word of god the heavens were
of old and the earth standing out of the
water and in the waters get to seven but
the heaven and the earth which are now
by that same word are kept in store in
other words the same creative word
mentioned in verse 5 is the word that
preserves in verse seven let me say it
again a biblical principle what creates
is what preserves and so we read in
hebrews chapter one from verse one to
three god who at sundry times and in
diverse manners speak in time past unto
the fathers by the prophets and in these
last days spoken unto us by his son whom
he hath appointed heir of all things by
whom also he made the world first three
who being the brightness of his glory
and the express image of his person
holding on things by the word of his
power the word of his power that holds
is the word of his power that created
now i realize it's very difficult to
accept this because we've grown up
seeing god very nicely kneeling down in
the dirt and screwing up there that's
what we've seen but i do not yet see
from the bible where that is thought or
from the writings of white
now as i said i'm not trying to promote
a doctrine i'm simply asking you just
consider
is there any evidence from scripture and
elderly to suggest
that all this creation was done by the
word of god
if you say
that creationists have human beings were
done by the hand the literal hand of god
then you've got to say it is by that
same literal hand that we're sustained
but the bible says no we're sustained by
the word of god therefore we must have
been created by the word of god you see
and so the question is
consider this as well if you read
genesis 2 verse 7 and the lord god
formed man of the dust of the ground you
read genesis 2 19 and out of the ground
the lord god from the every beast of the
earth you also have to say if god stoop
and form man with his hand he also stood
and form every land animal every bird
every fish because they will all go back
to dust when they die
and no one believes it
and so the formation of man
what i see in the bible in l.a why is
that it is the word of god and to deny
the word of god the power to create
physically is to deny the word of god
the power to create spiritually because
we know from first second peter chapter
1 verse 20 of first peter 1 23 being
born again not of corruptable seed but
of incorruptible by the word of god now
being born again that is spiritual
creation it is done by the word of god
james 1 18 of his own will be getting us
with the word of truth spiritual
creation
is uh is parallel with physical creation
in physical creation god created out of
nothing in spiritual creation we can't
bring raw materials to god and say begin
with this we have nothing to offer god
he makes us out of nothing and so what i
am seeing in the scripture of white is
that creation all six days was done by
the word of god when you understand that
you more clearly understand the
importance of the word for sustaining
you
the important because that is what made
you and it's a lot of christians have no
time for the bible they do not
understand the word of god made them
physically it is the word of god that
makes them spiritually and sustains them
then they begin to see it is the word so
jesus says man shall not live by bread
alone but by every word and the person
who said that was the one who created in
genesis 1. and so i offer that to you
for your consideration
if you find an elevator quotation that
says god use his hands and bow down and
stoop down and well send it to me or
verse that says that send it to me
that was long and tiring but i hope you
got something from it
okay
enough of this
yes we did we did the word of god oh my
god powerful the word of god is powerful
it creates it sustains it redeems
there's another quotation my good sister
i think it is desired it is page 320
paragraph two desire they just speak 320
paragraph two i believe it is crack down
white is commenting on the resurrection
of the widow's son the word of name luke
chapter seven and christ's sort of
funeral procession he touched the coffin
the guy uh he said young man i see until
they arise otherwise says as the word of
god which bid the first man live give
life to the to the to the widow's son
the youth of name now
as the word of god
which made the first man live
what's he saying it is by the word of
god adam came into existence
it gives us life today
saw the word you know
uh young man i see under the arise the
same word
and that word gives life to us
spiritually when the bible says in
ephesians 4 15 awake thou that sleepless
and arise from the dead that's the word
when you accept that word you come to
life spiritually because it has as much
power as let there be light or let it be
affirmative and so
you cannot have a teaching that
minimizes the word of god
but again i'm not promoting the doctrine
i'm simply saying consider what i've
said that's all i'm saying consider
amen amen
this is why we have to personalize the
promises of god friends yeah we can
insert your name in those bible verses
when you're writing promises because
god's word has power to change our
situations and bring things to past that
otherwise would not because god's word
cannot fail god's word fail
now elder screen i will
give way for one question that has been
asked by emmanuel yaboa who's on the
line all right he said please elder
what is your comment on uriah smith's
writings on revelation because sometimes
it causes distraction and confusion in
the church thanks
jorah smith who published daniel
revelation which was at one point the
leading authoritative text on daniel
revelation for the church ella white
endorsed it very heartily now that does
not mean she
she was saying every individual item of
information in the book was correct but
largely generally the book is very very
helpful there are a few inaccuracies yes
a few interpretations that are not
supported today but overall the book is
a very very helpful resource for the
study of daniel and revelation keep in
mind that no man-made product is
absolutely perfect but ellen white
endorsed it because she saw it provided
a lot of blessing to those who studied
and so yes it's not the perfect work no
other modern works perfect
but it is still of health very very
helpful in understanding the basics and
the essentials so you can know
how prophecy is moving and how you ought
to order your lives in association with
prophecy
so it's a very helpful book
amen amen far more helpful than it is uh
i hate to use the word harmful 99 plus
1.
buy it
please
no i was going to say indeed in fact um
for me personally in terms of building
my foundation in terms of you know these
prophetic symbols and and so forth i
first began with stephen and haskell's
lacrosse and shadow all right
understanding daniel and the revelation
i wrote daniel in the revelation by you
guys
that kind of helped solidify my
understanding and then adding you know
other sources and of course spirit of
prophecy and just competing scripture
with scripture
all right
yes so elder skeet i have so many other
questions and back stream facts and i
encourage you all to continue sharing
your questions stream facts has been
sending questions that persons have on
these q and a sessions that we have and
there are a multitude of questions
perhaps we may have to take a separate
session just dedicated to answering the
questions that persons have posed
because doing it at the end of the q a's
only gives us a short amount of time
your questions are noted and by god's
grace we will make the time to answer
them
let me say something dr denisha let me
say this i say it kindly but i say it
very directly
ask a question after you have made an
attempt to study the question yourself
bible study is fellowship with god
so the easy way is to say what does this
mean what does that mean that's the easy
way but you rob yourself as an
opportunity to fellowship with god let
me say it again bible study is as much
fellowship with god as is prayer or
singing and so don't miss the
opportunity to fellowship with god
through bible even if you do not
understand you have not lost because
you've made an attempt i've said it
before i'll say it again if there's a
difficult bible passage you try to
understand it you come away unsuccessful
your mind is still blessed because you
have exerted your mind against a divine
force do not sidestep bible study and
simply ask people you know whom did cain
marry or whatever try to study for
yourself because the bible has a promise
john 16 30 and how be it when he the
spirit of truth is come he will guide
you into all truth there is a promise
psalm 119 verse 18 david prayed open
down mine eyes that i may behold
understands out of thy law psalm 32
verse 8 of 25 verse 4 show me thy ways
of lord teach me thy past teach me god
will take your bible go to god and using
scripture scripture scriptures see what
you can learn
when you've exhausted your your efforts
then you say to someone i have studied
here's what i've come up with i need
help but too many people i'm not judging
anyone too many people take the easy way
and they simply say tell me
tell me tell me and so save me the
hassle of bible study it is not a hassle
bible study
is fellowship with god
and i wanted to say that do not skip
bible study just to go the easy way and
tell someone tell me but please send
your questions and god bless you
hey mental friends we have to study for
ourselves in fact
one of the ways that i also started
doing bible study was by just asking
questions
asking questions and then asking god to
you know show me the answers sometimes
one week sometimes two weeks sometimes a
month on one question and that brings up
another point not to belabor it there's
no need for us to rush to learn all of
god's word at one time that's right
verse by verse
lying upon line compare one scripture
with another try to get as much as you
can out of that one verse and it would
do us more justice than reading five
chapters just to say we've read five
chapters that's right very true
all right so we have come to the end of
our q and a session and on your feet we
just
praise god for you and your ministry we
extend fair and great thanks to you for
taking the time once again to join us
for another q and a session we thank you
as well for
staying over time as always to answer
the questions from the live audience and
doing your very best to always build the
context so that we understand the
background of the question and also the
question itself
may the lord continue to bless you your
wife your entire family and protect you
and your wife even as you travel to and
fro sharing the word of the lord and god
bless you too god bless all the
listeners i really mean that and if the
little children listening i always pray
for little children may god especially
bless the little boys and the little
girls because samuel was a little boy at
one point before he became a mighty
prophet and so may god particularly
bless the little boys and the little
girls were listening because we live in
a very dangerous
society and environment and the devil
they're under tremendous attack that
children from many years ago did not
have to deal with and so may god
preserve your children put a hedge of
protection around them so that when
christ comes it will be ready to meet in
god bless the little children anyone
listening who is not a seventh adventist
thank you for joining and please
continue to join us as we try to unravel
the word of god god bless all of those
you listen and all the countries that
tuned in
amen thank you so much elder skeet for
pronouncing that
that blessing we as well express sincere
thanks to those of you that are on this
zoom line those of you watching on
youtube and on facebook or if you're on
twitch
um we thank you for tuning in and we
pray that you know zelda skeet said the
time before that this is not just an
academic exercise but that would truly
take these things that we have learned
and by god's grace and through the power
of his holy spirit apply it to our lives
all right so i let me just continue
on let me see sister kadisha i believe
you are on
miss modest sister kadisha will be
giving us a meditation song it's his
life for mine
friends we are reminded indeed that the
plan of salvation has been brought forth
and that jesus made the sacrifice in the
beginning on our
pass and the enemy the satanic trinity
is doing everything in his power to keep
us from taking hold of that salvation
but we pray that you are
affirmed in the word of god affirmed
that god has made a provision
for us and through his grace and his
power
we can in our state can be and are saved
i pray you are blessed
sister khadijah modest will be
ministering his life for mine
[Music]
his heart was broken
mind was mended
[Music]
he became
the nails that held him
set me free
[Music]
his life for mine
his life
could it ever
be
that he will die
god saw
[Applause]
he gave his life
healing
his blood
to fill my soul
his crown of thorns
made me roll you'll see
his song will get me
joy
his life for mine
[Music]
[Laughter]
how could it ever
be
that he would die
god saw with us
to save
our rights not me
[Laughter]
he was despised and rejected
[Music]
i am loved and accepted
[Applause]
is
[Laughter]
could it ever
be
that he
would
my
[Music]
amen amen powerful ministry sister
modest
god gave his life for ours
friends this is why we cannot spurn
salvation
full and free it is for us that god has
given us the victory let's claim it in
jesus name
i extend thanks sincere thanks again to
elder randy skeet for answering the
questions and giving of his time to
spend with us
and um brother aj i noted your question
on facebook god willing we have q a
sessions live q a sessions with elder
randy skeet every fourth sabbath of the
month at two o'clock p.m eastern
standard time and eldesquit has been
very faithful
in tuning
participating
as well i would like to express
gratitude to brother anthony ralph
for asking the questions some questions
to elder skeet and adding personal
commentary i thank sister modest for
ministering so beautifully his life for
mine and in advance i thank elder george
francis for doing the closing prayer and
interestingly enough he preached today
this sabbath at east new york and he
spoke about those three words and three
words that god would often use to
express his greatness and he spoke about
let there be and it is finished things
that elder skeet spoke about
in our discussion today so we thank god
for using the george in that capacity
now before i have elder george do the
closing prayer i invite you all to join
us by god's grace november 27th at 2
o'clock p.m eastern standard time so for
the aj you can prepare for november 27
at 2 o'clock p.m eastern standard time
for another q a session with elder randy
skeet this time on the remnant church so
feel free to tune in in fact
like and subscribe so that you know when
we are live and upload new content so
that you can stay informed and
participate to those of you that are
watching
on zoom watching on facebook or youtube
and or youtube thank you so much for
tuning in and we pray that you were
blessed and encouraged by this session
and that that and that we would all be
drawn closer to god and take this gospel
to all the world even being
living witnesses for our lord and savior
thank you all and god bless elder george
you may do the closing prayer
oh let me
allow you to
[Music]
oh yes sorry
uh
i believe elder george i know you're
praying but for some reason
we are not hearing you
so let me
father we coming for you and giving you
a thumbs up
all that you have done for us so give
your thanks lord because you're an
awesome god
i give you thanks for your word because
we can find peace hope and redemption
we absolutely help us to always remember
that
regardless of what will happen in this
world we can always find comfort in
knowing that when we are wrapped up tied
up in you
our salvation is secured
so i ask that lord and may continue to
bless us prepare us for your kingdom i
pray in jesus name
amen
amen and amen thank you so much again
brother george for that prayer and to
those of you that tuned in thank you we
pray you are blessed and have a
wonderful rest of the sabbath day